ich habe mal wieder überhaupt gar keine
Ahnung was ich kochen soll und da gibt
es eine App die sehr hilfreich sein kann
tiktok dort gibt es super praktische
Rezepte z.B bei admax pane auf dem
Profil Link in der Beschreibung aber
auch viel zu komplizierte komische oder
auch einfach schlechtere Rezepte wir
machen heute die drei ersten Rezepte die
uns angezeigt werden einfach so wie sie
kommt machen wir uns auf die Suche nach
dem ersten Rezept
wow okay
crispy Palme Baby sweetcorn Butter
chilifex Petersilie Parmesan und
Knoblauch einfach zusammen mischen die
Dinger reinhauen in Parmesan auf dem
Backblech boah das sieht richtig gut aus
und so knusprige Ecken Chili mai dazu
okay ich glaube ich muss nicht mehr
sagen das ist unser erstes Rezept wir
haben alles besorgt was wir brauchen ich
habe schon ein bisschen Butter
geschmolzen
Zuckermais gar nicht so leicht zu
bekommen wir haben jetzt welchen aus der
Dose genommen ich hoffe das funktioniert
genauso gut für die Soße für Mario
Petersilie Knoblauch und Parmesan Käse
von dem habe ich schon ein bisschen
gerieben durch den werden wir gleich den
meisten ziehen ich glaube das kann
eigentlich nur lecker werden dieses
Rezept wobei ich so diese
Geschmackskombination von dem salzigen
kann dann mit dem süßen meistens so und
mir sehr gut vorstellen kann
einmal schön halbieren
dann nehme ich mir hier ein Schälchen
gibt meine geschmolzene Butter hinein
das kann nur lecker werden so
geschmolzene Butter kann man dann
Chiliflocken reinigt hier direkt mit
Knoblauchzehe rein auch Knoblauch stelle
ich mir richtig geil vor so
geschmacklich dazu können wir das ganze
einfach einmal reinstreifen dann nehme
ich ein bisschen Petersilie
runterschneiden
ganz schön fein gestimmt ich glaube das
hat nur Vorteile gegenüber getrockneter
Petersilie dann noch eine Prise von
unserem Parmesan kann man ein bisschen
mehr runter geschmolzen die wird jetzt
auch noch unter das ist auf jeden Fall
schwimmt und hier unseren Mais easy
bedecken können jetzt Leute abgeht die
Post Mais in diese Würzmischung und dann
in den Parmesan rausholen tschüss
Kolben es sind die Mischung dann den
Parmesan oder leute guckt euch das bitte
einfach mal an deine Sauerei aber das
sieht so unfassbar gut aus
so kommt das ganze jetzt bei 200 Grad in
den Backofen bis es schön knusprig ist
und der Zwischenzeit machen wir jetzt
aus Mario und Schach nämlich
perfekten Dip wenn das Ganze gleich aus
dem Ofen kommt so und jetzt holen wir
die guten Dinge ungefähr 10 15 Minuten
drin waren wir schauen uns das mal an
sind leicht angebräunt goldig aber nicht
verbrannt natürlich also los geht's
die guten Dinge haben wir jetzt mal raus
ah Leute da haben wir die guten Dinger
guckt euch das mal an Leute es sieht
ganz ähnlich dem Video aus wir haben so
diese kleinen Parmesan Flakes die
inmitten der Mini Maiskolben sind auch
die Dinger genannt die guten Dinger dazu
die Chili Maja kurz abkühlen lassen dann
probieren wir der meistens ein bisschen
abgekühlt und eine Sache ist mir direkt
aufgefallen der ist ein bisschen weich
wenn wir drauf drücken ich glaube das
hätten wir nicht wenn der ganz frisch
wäre weil so ist ja quasi schon weiche
aus der Dose einmal frei kratzen 20
Minuten braucht er das jetzt insgesamt
im Ofen
ach schön aus ne einmal rein
Entschuldigung
krass aber konsistenzmäßig ist das nicht
so geil sieht ja auch irgendwie knusprig
aus aber dafür braucht man safe den
frischen babymeister hier mit so einem
schönen Netz ausgeschmolzenem Käse außen
rum und fertig mit der Mario erst recht
also auf jeden Fall eine geile
ausgefallene Beilage
schauen wir jetzt nach dem zweiten
Rezept
oh die sind immer krass die liebe ich
diese Videos
oh Steak Butter burners oh Leute das
sieht richtig gut aus so schön arosieren
mit dem ganzen und mit der braunen
Butter vom anbraten die
macht man in die Banane perfekt mit dem
Rest Steak mit dieser Soße okay Leute
sorry aber das müssen wir machen Steak
Butter burnings das ist unser
zweiter Reduktion dafür machen wie das
allein schon klingt das ist Fan was wir
jetzt noch eine schöne ist auf jeden
Fall was Feines ich habe hier eine
Charlotte halbiere ich und die schneide
ich einfach einmal fein runter eine
Zitrone die ich halbiere jetzt gebe ich
in meine Pfanne 75 ml Weißweinessig zack
meine Zwiebel Estragon und den Saft
einer halben Zitrone kennt den Spaß
immer in die Hand pressen und dann
bleiben die Kerne nämlich drin zu kommen
noch ein paar Pfefferkörner so erhitzen
wir das Ganze bis es um dreiviertel
reduziert ist das ist reduziert jetzt
gebe ich durch einen Sieb in unsere
Schüssel und was zurück bleibt ist die
Essenz ist purem Geschmacks soll das
ganze noch ein bisschen ausdrücken es
ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen wenig
Flüssigkeit ich habe es gar nicht so
lange reduzieren lassen aber irgendwie
keine Ahnung wir haben die Maßangaben
verfolgt ein Video macht jetzt im
nächsten Schritt diese mit der
Flüssigkeit mit der Reduktion über die
Hitze und schlägt das ganze hier drin
einmal auf bis sie sich im Volumen durch
die Luft die man rein schlägt verdoppelt
so Freunde es sieht gar nicht so
schlecht aus also bisschen gerührt und
jetzt haben wir schon so eine schöne
cremige Masse aus unserer Reduktion
gewonnen so lassen wir das jetzt einfach
mal ruhen denn jetzt machen wir ein
Steak jetzt mache ich mir mein Steak
werden
ist großzügig von allen Seiten wir
nehmen ein bisschen Öl in die Pfanne und
wir Platz
das heißt so dass ich eine schöne Kruste
bilden kann wenn eine schöne Farbe dran
haben wenn wir das ganze jetzt brate ich
noch die Seiten und dann können wir auch
schon abonnieren jetzt wird Zeit Butter
hinzuzufügen und zwar eine ganze Ecke
175 Gramm dazu noch die Kräuter
Knoblauchzehen und hier stimmt irgendwie
so einiges nicht am Rezept wir haben 175
Gramm Butter laut Rezept und das ist
doch viel weniger weil unser Steak
schwimmt also
ich weiß irgendwie nicht ich meine ganz
schlecht sein eigentlich nicht um
ehrlich zu sein ohne wir nehmen jetzt
einmal die Steaks raus die sind wirklich
am schwimmen gewesen darin und die sind
auch probiert das sollen unsere kurz
sein aber irgendwie fällt das fast
auseinander jetzt haben wir auf jeden
Fall eine schöne gefreutliche Butter
erhalten die ich hier einmal durch das
Sieb abschütte und das sollte jede Menge
Geschmack drin sein also boah sieht
schon verdammt gut aus jetzt haben wir
die Aufgabe hier langsam aber sicher die
Steak runter einzugehen ich habe ein
bisschen Angst dass nicht funktioniert
weil es geht ja nicht um gutes Steak
sondern eben um die nächste Soße in dem
Rezept ist noch die Rede von einem
kleinen Kind Cayennepfeffer es soll noch
ein bisschen Essen reinkommen das machen
wir natürlich auch alles strengendere
Rezept aber bisher bin ich eher
enttäuscht ist dieser Teller diese ganze
Unordnung Wert ich habe da so ein Gefühl
aber ich nehme mir mal hier so einen
schönen Steak Bike rein in die der Nähe
ist und probiere
ist schon sehr lecker aber ein geiles
Steak ist halt auch so sehr lecker weil
das ist dann eher so ein grundsätzliches
Ding ob ich so beim nächsten fühle oder
nicht weil es ist super aufwendig und
das Rezept ist glaube ich nicht das
Beste für sowas schon irgendwie geil so
die Säure von Essig und Zitrone so zu
diesem Steak das ist gut
ich flüssig genug
Butter Explosion aber
sorry das ist halt einfach zu viel
schauen wir doch nach einem letzten
Rezept jetzt fehlt uns noch ein drittes
Rezept und das finden wir jetzt heraus
Leute diese Videos ne die können mir das
wirklich den ganzen Tag anschauen
ach
oha hot honey Christy Halloumi Beiz
durch Parmesan und Semmelbrösel panieren
und dann einfach einen scharfen Honig
dazu ist nicht wirklich ein Rezept Video
aber es ist so einfach das ist intuitiv
ist und es sieht verdammt gut aus
Freunde Nummer 3 kein Snack noch zum
Abschluss lass uns gut gehen kommen wir
zu Rezept Nummer drei Leute lustig am
Ende des Tages wird man lustig
ich habe hier einen Halloumi und ich
hoffe wirklich inständig das ist am Ende
des Tages nicht knatschig ist weil ich
hasse
das einmal in der Mitte und jetzt
schneiden wir das ganze einfach nur in
gleichförmige Würfel zack zack zack zack
gleich ist auf der anderen Seite ich
sage euch ganz ehrlich das ist so ein
simples Rezept es kann Loki nur gut sein
hier habe ich ein paar Brot da rein
reichen ein bisschen Parmesan 2:1 vom
Anteil her das ganze gebe ich jetzt hier
in eine Schüssel Pfanne heißt schon vor
mit ein bisschen Sonnenblumenöl jetzt
zwei Eier die wir ganz einfach
verquirlen dann können wir auch schon
den Halloumi in die Eiermischung geben
und wenn der Halloumi benetzt ist in die
Mischung ein bisschen durchwerfen eine
Sache müssen wir bemerken ich backe das
gleich in der Pfanne aus weil im Video
hat ja gesehen dass es auf dem Backblech
aber auf der Website steht dass es in
der Pfanne mit Olivenöl gebacken werden
soll und genau das machen wir jetzt
einfach weil ich kann ja auch nicht
vorstellen dass es so knusprig und
crunchy wird wenn wir das Ganze im
Backofen machen
[Musik]
und von allen Seiten knusprig unsere
Halloween sind schön knusprig sehen aber
ein bisschen anders aus als in dem Video
dass wir gesehen haben irgendwie hält
die Panade nicht so gut dann habe ich
das Gefühl ein bisschen Chili in einer
Akazienhonig unser hot chili honey
es klingt schon sehr sehr crispy und
Crunch wie muss ich sagen jetzt kommt
oben drüber der Chili Honig jetzt ist
das alles noch schön mit dem Honig
bedeckt jetzt nehme ich immer so ein
Würfel das ist schon relativ nah an dem
vom Rezept jetzt haben wir hier so ein
Halloween Würfel und ich mache das Ding
mal auf
[Musik]
geil das hat nicht so ein Schießpulver
so richtig aber ich glaube das wird
schon sehr lecker sein
mit Halloumi sehr sehr lecker sogar
knusprig herzhaft süß leichte dezente
Schärfe solltet ihr unbedingt mal
ausprobieren hat euch das Video gefallen
hat gerne einen Daumen hoch sollen wir
noch ein paar weitere tiktok Rezepte
testen dann schreibt es in die
Kommentare sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder bis dahin ciao